hi my name is alvin i like to bake at
home so i thought it'd be fun to make
chocolate cake one with 20 ingredients
one with 10 ingredients and one with two
ingredients i'm curious to see if more
ingredients equals better and i'm
honestly just excited to make and eat a
lot of cake so let's get started first
up i'm going to make the 20 ingredient
chocolate cake
to start with the dry mix i'm combining
all purpose flour
sugar dutch processed cocoa powder which
is pretty important baking soda baking
powder and a little bit of salt because
i think salt and desserts is really
great and this will just get sifted
until all the big lumps get shown and
then you kind of press them back in
until all the big lumps become small
dust and
everybody's happy so this is the dry
mixture for the cake
this next part is kind of cool some
stout dark beer
some vanilla extract and some espresso
powder honestly i think this is pretty
awesome because this will add a lot of
flavors to me this is almost like a
flavor enhancement potion that really is
going to make the cake taste good all
right so now the frosting i'm going to
use two sticks of unsalted butter at
this point i really forgot that i was
supposed to beat the butter with the
sugar and not have it in the dry mix but
i think it's fine after that i'm going
to put in some eggs just one by one so
that it doesn't clump up too quickly i
like to scrape down the sides in between
just because i like to keep things tidy
and after that this is probably going to
freak a lot of people out we're going to
use mayonnaise so i initially thought
this was kind of weird but if you really
think about it mayo is eggs oil salt
essentially what we already have in the
cake just adding more of the same
alternating between wet and dry
ingredients as you mix helps the mixture
become more even and prevents a lot of
huge clumps after a while the mixture
will look all soft and nice and become a
really really delicious smelling and
looking cake batter i mean yeah this oh
yeah look at that that looks good
vaping down the sides until the rest is
done but
this is a very
oh yeah that's what i'm talking about
probably my favorite part is that dark
chocolate chunks go directly into the
batter so if you like chocolate i think
you're gonna really like this cake
i'm dividing this batter into three
eight inch cake pans which i've put
parchment sort of greased all around
don't forget to taste your batter as
well even though my mom says i shouldn't
do it but i am an adult now and i do
what i want
i'm making these in a preheated oven at
325 fahrenheit until they're done
while the cake's baked i'm going to make
the frosting i'm going to start with
three sticks of butter beating it up
like it owes me money then i'm going to
add in some vanilla just froze some
flavor as well as some more dutch
processed cocoa powder i think it really
makes a difference if the cocoa powder
is dutch processed cocoa powder is a lot
darker and it just tastes so much more
like really really good chocolate some
salt and some powdered sugar now this
has a lot of powdered sugar so i'm
making sure to add it a little bit by a
little bit and when it gets a little dry
i add milk
while i'm doing this it kind of spilled
all over my kitchen so we're going to
skip past that part and go voila look
chocolate frosting done
okay
and the cakes are done so i'm gonna pull
them out of the oven and i'm letting
them cool on a wire rack and just until
they're able to be handled and after
they are
i flip them out onto a rack upside down
flipping the cake upside down while it's
warm helps flatten any of the top so you
don't actually have to trim the cake
once the cakes are completely cool i'm
going to attempt to decorate it so cake
decorating is one of my biggest
weaknesses i'm terrible at it so i'm
going to attempt to try to make this
cake look good if you're a pastry chef
or a cake decorator or professional out
there that's watching i am sorry
i don't know how to do this correctly
probably could have done a lot better
here but i think you know it's it's it's
all right
please don't yell at me in the comments
that would really hurt my feelings but
hey not bad for a first attempt at this
cake decoration the recipe calls to add
some nice fresh fruit over the top half
cut strawberries and some raspberries
can cover a lot of mistakes so
nice
do you want to cut a slice and eat it
because i'm very hungry at this point
and i also just want to see how i did
all right a little moment of truth to
see what the cross section looks like
and
all right not bad
this is the 20 ingredient chocolate cake
i'm going to be tasting all these cakes
at the end so stay tuned all right next
up i'm going to make a 10 ingredient
chocolate cake this one is a take on a
box cake mix so i'm starting out with
two packets of boxed cake mix
some eggs some oil and instead of water
i use cold brew because i think this
really adds a lot of flavor coffee and
chocolate go together really well and
it's my way of making a cake that
doesn't taste like butt cakes mix and
this is the kind of cake i would make
for my friends and hope that they don't
notice that it was boxed but if they see
this video
sorry guys you're cool but i was lazy
same thing batter separate them cake
pans and i'm baking these also at 325
for about
30 to 35 minutes until they are ready
my experience with cake mix is that it
always seems to dome no matter what i do
after baking so i'm going to need to
trim it later i'm making a chocolate
cream cheese frosting so starting off
with cream cheese butter beanie them
together like they stole my lunch and
after that i'm going to add again some
cocoa powder usually when i make this i
don't usually have dutch processed cocoa
powder on hand so i just use normal
cocoa powder which is fine
and same thing as the other frosting
just adding powdered sugar
slowly bit by bit until the frosting is
nice really just watch and look how
smooth everything is and how silky the
texture is i mean it doesn't really get
much better than this and to trim the
cake these did dome a little bit so i'm
going to do my best and trim it as best
as i can
there's probably a better way to do this
i don't really know how but
yeah
okay and to decorate going to try to do
this thing i mean i might have improved
slightly from the first time around but
i will say this cake spinner thing or
whatever that things makes it a lot
easier because then you know kind of
fixes all the mistakes for me so after
this is as smooth as i personally can
handle to decorate i actually like to
put chocolate chips on the outside i
think it's a nice decoration because
again it helps me hide the fact that i'm
not good at cake decorating and i think
it looks pretty and it tastes good and
chances are if you're making this for
someone who likes chocolate they're
probably going to like chocolate chips
too so kind of a win-win situation
when all the chips are pretty much
almost on i like to use some parchment
and kind of rub against the side so that
it really shapes up the cake into a nice
round shape and after that when you peel
the parchment away you kind of get a
more
aligned cake feel if that's a word i
don't know if that's a word but
yeah that's the cake i think it all
tastes good
oh that was a good cut alvin
that was a nice one
take a second slice
oh jesus that is a huge slice
oh this looks nice look at that look at
that cross section
this is the 10 ingredient chocolate cake
with cream cheese frosting and an
upgraded box mix
and last but not least i'm gonna make a
two ingredient chocolate cake for this
one i'm starting off with a lot of
chocolate bars just breaking them into
chunks because the goal is to put them
in the microwave and heat them up until
you can sort of melt them and become
this really beautiful silky chocolate
puddle that you want to jump in
and
some egg yolks total of eight egg yolks
that i've separated from the whites and
this part you know might seem weird
because everything's getting all chunky
and clumpy but that's part of the recipe
and with egg whites that i've separated
and kept out i'm going to beat them
until i get them to about soft peaks not
too hard until they're just looking like
clouds
and yes these these do look like clouds
nice
to first i'm just going to sacrifice a
little bit to really whip into this
chocolate egg yolk mixture just so that
it becomes smooth and slowly but surely
whip in the rest of the egg whites until
they're folded in and they're nice and
smooth and it looks like that and
looks good looks good and i'm going to
put them into a smaller cake pan usually
a springform pan just because this cake
isn't meant to be a triple tier cake and
this one goes into an oven again at
around 325
for about 45 minutes it's pretty dense
it rises a lot because the egg whites
have a lot of air in them but this will
sink a little bit after it's cooled so
you let this hang out here until
it's nice and ready
okay so this one is cooled and just
trimming the top because it is kind of
chunky and lumpy this cake is definitely
a little bit more dense than the other
two because i think it's literally just
chocolate and eggs and now we're gonna
make the glaze this is just some melted
chocolate again microwaved and heated
until it's nice and smooth oh yeah
that's that's smooth
you guys are probably gonna get mad at
me because technically this is a third
ingredient i'm adding a little bit of
water because i'm making a ganache which
you can do with water and chocolate just
even though they don't mix if you keep
stirring it'll become smooth
and glossy and silky just like that
technically water is a third ingredient
but guys it's water please help me out
here
i'm a little bit more relieved because i
don't have to decorate it as nicely as
the other cakes and just try to cover
this whole cake and
make that oh yeah that's a nice good one
kind of digging this world is i don't
know why it came up with it on the spot
and it's fun to do i will say it is very
very fun to do
but yeah i probably could have
definitely made that look a little bit
better but
again this is a two ingredient chocolate
cake
i just think it's really awesome that
this entire chocolate cake is just three
uh two ingredients you know eggs
chocolate water
this is a two ingredient or three
ingredient chocolate cake depending on
how mad you are at what i did
so time to taste starting with the 20
ingredient chocolate cake this is really
good it's super chocolatey all the other
stuff we put in it like the beer and the
mayo really just kind of adds up to
something really really great eating the
10 ingredient one the cake itself is
still really good the frosting is
different because we use cream cheese
and the chocolate chips add a really
nice touch
the two ingredient cake is probably the
most interesting out of all of them it's
got a more dense cakey texture the taste
itself is really good it's basically
like 90 chocolate so it's really
chocolatey
so does the ingredient amount matter i
think it definitely does i think what's
really important is the quality of those
ingredients the 20 ingredient chocolate
cake has a lot of things in it the dutch
process cocoa powder the beer
the mayo all really help enhance the
quality of the cake itself as well as
the frosting even though we didn't use
dutch processed cocoa powder in the 10
ingredient chocolate cake adding those
chocolate chips at the end increased the
chocolatiness of the whole cake which is
a great idea the two ingredient
chocolate cake punches far above its
weight class it has 10 times less the
ingredients of the 20 gritty chocolate
cake but compared flavor-wise it's
really really good even though it's not
that same soft cake and frosting texture
no matter how many ingredients you want
to make your cake with if you use really
good ingredients and choose ingredients
that add a lot of value i think you're
going to end up with a great cake
i'll see you guys next time happy baking
[Music]
[Music]
you